tu devant vous comme la première
mairesse de montréal
c'était il ya deux ans déjà une élection
historique et des promesses ambitieuses
mais rapidement bien des montréalais
déchantent
nous allons agir de façon responsable et
investis en infrastructures de lui à son
premier budget valérie plan annonce une
hausse de la taxe sur l'eau qui
contribue à hausser les taxes au delà de
l'inflation ce qu'elle avait promis de
ne pas faire vous cacherai pas mon
enthousiasme ans et mon plaisir et
rapidement les annonces s'enchaînent
autoproclamé mairesse de la mobilité
elle réalise plusieurs promesses ces 300
nouveaux autobus hybrides s'en viennent
les premiers rouleront dans les
prochaines semaines elle va aussi
chercher un premier financement pour sa
fameuse ligne rose
le tronçon entre la chine et le centre
ville mais on vise maintenant un tramway
est plutôt qu'un métro le réseau express
vélo est aussi en marche
cinq des dix sept axes de ces autoroutes
cyclistes seront complétés en 2021
promesses non tenues par contre d'offrir
le transport en commun moins cher ou
gratuits aux aînés aux enfants et aux
plus démunis encore aujourd'hui la
tarification sociale reste un rêve comme
promis l'escouade mobilité est lancé
pour désengorger la ville mais fait elle
vraiment différence circulation chantier
rendent fous et montréalais il y a les
automobilistes d'un côté les cyclistes
de l'autre déplore l'opposition
en résumé c'est que ces deux ans de
divisions par dogmatisme
c'est une administration qui croit avoir
la vérité absolue
exemple dit lionel perez
l'insatisfaction entourant le projet
pilote sur camilien-houde valérie
plantes ayant promis de s'attaquer à la
circulation de transit sur le mont royal
je dois dire que je balaie du revers de
la main cette critique au contraire je
pense que je
j'ai la capacité on le voit en trop avec
l'a35o logique de rassembler les gens
autour de moi
victimes collatérales des chantiers les
commerçants ont eu droit eux à 25
millions de dollars pour compenser
certaines de leurs pertes c'était un
engagement développer 12 mai logements
sociaux et abordables en 4 1 c'est une
scène qui est ambitieuse un mi-mandat un
peu plus de six mille deux cents
logements sociaux s'apprêtent à sortir
de terre sur les 12000 valérie plante va
aussi de l'avant avec sa promesse dit du
20 20 20
dans deux ans les promoteurs devront
construire 20% de logements sociaux
abordables et familiaux dans leurs
nouveaux immeubles au cours des deux
dernières années il y a aussi eu des
bancs puis des moins bons en cours parmi
les bons coups cette capacité de valérie
plantes par exemple de négocier avec le
gouvernement du québec
ou bien son souci de transparence parmi
les moins bons coups on se souviendra de
ce discours prononcé uniquement en
anglais ou bien de la gestion difficile
du déneigement l'hiver dernier pour ce
bilan mi mandat valérie plantes se
donnent une note de cet ennemi sur 10
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio-canada
m'ont rien